A new month brings a new batch of content
to stream on Netflix.
From a Netflix Original movie that will make
you swoon to new series to binge, here are
the best movies and TV shows to watch on Netflix
in February 2021.
Perhaps the biggest Netflix Original movie
of February 2021 is the long-awaited third
and final installment in the To All the Boys
cinematic franchise: To All the Boys: Always
and Forever.
Based on author Jenny Han's novel Always and
Forever, Lara Jean, the film picks up after
the events of To All the Boys: P.S.
I Still Love You, which saw Lara Jean Covey
enduring a rough patch with her fake-boyfriend-turned-real-boyfriend
Peter Kavinsky.
In To All the Boys: Always and Forever, Lara
Jean embarks on two trips that will completely
change her life and cause her to reevaluate
what her future will look like after she graduates
high school.
Will Peter and Lara Jean stick together in
the end, or will Lara Jean decide she wants
to spread her wings and be a single, independent
butterfly as she heads off to college?
You'll have to wait until the movie hits Netflix
on February 12 to find out.
Before then, though, there are a number of
fantastic Netflix Original flicks to get excited
about.
On February 3, Black Beach, about a lawyer
facing his dark past after he reunites with
an old friend, and All My Friends Are Dead,
about a group of friends' memorable New Year's
Eve party, drop on Netflix.
February 5 brings the black-and-white drama
Malcolm & Marie, which centers on the title
characters unraveling the darker parts of
their relationship during the night of Malcolm's
movie premiere.
Though Netflix is getting into the lovey-dovey
spirit in February 2021, that doesn't mean
that all its film offerings for the month
skew toward the romantic.
Some do, but others hit all sorts of other
emotions, sure to satisfy the various types
of cinephiles out there all month long.
"You mustn't be afraid to dream a little bigger,
darling."
Looking to revisit a mind-bending Christopher
Nolan film?
Stream Inception on Netflix beginning on February
1.
Want to distract yourself from the candy-hearts-and-cutesy-card-filled
holiday of February and remember the cheery
days of December, all while laughing at Chevy
Chase's wild antics?
National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation is the
movie for you, and it's arriving on Netflix
on the first of the month.
Action movie fans will want to set aside some
time to watch Jason Statham in The Bank Job,
about the Baker Street robbery that took place
in London in 1971, on February 1, and War
Dogs, starring Miles Teller and Jonah Hill
as two arms dealers carrying out a massive
ammo supply deal, on February 8.
The first of the month brings Martin Scorsese's
jaw-dropping psychological thriller Shutter
Island, while later, on February 21, both
The Conjuring and The Conjuring 2 arrive to
the streamer's digital shelves.
Near the end of the month, on February 26,
queue up two movies that are returning to
Netflix after some time away, and one that's
new to the platform: Captain Fantastic, a
comedy-drama about a family emerging from
a decade-long isolation and rejoining society;
No Escape, the action-thriller starring Owen
Wilson as a family man stuck in a foreign
country amid an uprising; and Our Idiot Brother,
featuring Paul Rudd as the titular character
who gives his three sisters all sorts of grief.
Netflix Original series to keep your eyes
on throughout February 2021 include Firefly
Lane, a drama following two best friends who
experience trials and tribulations throughout
their 30 years of companionship; The Crew,
a comedy set in a NASCAR garage where a seasoned
crew chief clashes with his team of millennial
staff; and Ginny & Georgia, which follows
the title characters as their small family
settles down in New England.
Additionally, you'll want to make some space
in your Netflix queue for Nadiya Bakes, a
cookery series featuring Nadiya Hussain of
The Great British Bake-Off fame, which will
hit the streamer on February 12.
Early on in the month, the platform is scooping
up the third installment of the anthology
series The Sinner, this one centered on a
man named Jamie Burns; viewers can stream
it beginning on February 6.
If more family-friendly fare is what you're
after this February, the first two seasons
of Nickelodeon's iCarly, arriving on the 8th
of the month, should do the trick.
Looking to balance laughs with thrills next
month?
Check out the third season of NBC's Good Girls,
starring Christina Hendricks, Retta, and Mae
Whitman as three mothers who decide to take
their fates and their finances in their own
hands by robbing a supermarket.
Good Girls season 3 will be available to stream
starting on February 16.
Speaking of heart-racing, February 24 marks
the arrival of the second season of Two Sentence
Horror Stories, the anthology series comprised
of 30-minute horror shorts.
The episodes will air on the CW throughout
January before hitting Netflix at the end
of February.
Both the stand-up comedy and documentary sections
of Netflix's library will grow a bit bigger
in February, starting with the arrival of
season 2 of the Emmy-winning special Tiffany
Haddish Presents: They Ready and the Netflix
debut of Strip Down, Rise Up.
In this collection of They Ready, Haddish
introduces six of her favorite comedians who
will perform short but hilarious sets.
Strip Down, Rise Up is a documentary that
explores how women who pole dance are reclaiming
their authority, autonomy, and confidence
through "movement and meaning."
A few days later, on February 10, the true
crime documentary Crime Scene: The Vanishing
at the Cecil Hotel arrives on Netflix.
The first in a series of documentaries focused
on crime-scene locations, The Vanishing at
Cecil Hotel recounts the events that took
place leading up to, during, and after the
disappearance and death of Elisa Lam, a Canadian
student whose body was found in the Cecil
Hotel's water tank.
For a markedly more lighthearted documentary
experience, check out Pelé, which tells the
story of how the ultra-famous Brazilian footballer
became the sports icon he's remembered as
today.
Pelé hits Netflix on February 23.
That same day, Brian Regan's stand-up special
On the Rocks will be available to stream on
Netflix, and on the 12th the month, Hate by
Dani Rovira also joins the Netflix library.
Early in the month, Erased and Lila & Eve
will depart from Netflix — followed by Don't
Knock Twice on February 7 and A Bad Moms Christmas
on February 10.
The following day, the Will Ferrell-Mark Wahlberg
buddy cop movie The Other Guys will have its
final day in the sun on the streaming platform.
On Valentine's Day, both Alone in Berlin and
Hostiles say goodbye to Netflix.
Other notable films leaving Netflix in February
include the hilarious and charming Emma Stone
comedy Easy A, the classic Scorsese crime
film Goodfellas, the heart-wrenching romantic
drama A Walk to Remember, and Clint Eastwood's
2008 drama Gran Torino.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix originals are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.